>>> TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO,
NEW, SHOWS UKRAINIAN FORCES,
WELL, DESTROYING A RUSSIAN TANK.
THIS AS SOURCES TE CNN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
PROVIDE UKRAINE WITH ANOTHER
WEAPON IN ITS ARSENAL, WHAT ARE
KNOWN AS SWITCHBLADE DRONES,
THAT'S A PICTURE THERE ALSO
KNOWN AS SUICIDE DRONES, THEY
CAN FLY INTO A TARGET AND
DESTROY IT.
WHILE WE DON'T KNOW WHICH MODEL
UKRAINE WILL GET, THE LARGEST IS
CAPABLE OF HITTING TARGETS FROM
20 MILES AWAY.
ONE OF AN ARRAY OF WEAPONS THAT
THE U.S. AND NATO PARTNERS ARE
NOW SENDING IN.
MY NEXT GUEST SAYS MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE BY THE U.S. AND NATO AND
NOW.
WITH ME NOW REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINZINGER FROM
ILLINOIS.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
THIS MORNING.
>> YOU BET.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN FORWARD LEANING
ON THE SUPPORT THAT THE U.S. AND
NATO HAVE TO OFFER, INCLUDING
KEEPING UP WITH THE POSSIBILITY
OF A NO-FLY ZONE.
THEY HAVE NOW ARE AND HAVE SENT
IN A HOST OF AIR DEFENSE SYSTEMS
INCLUDING THE S-300, WHICH IS
HIGH ALTITUDE.
I SPOKE WITH YOUR COLLEAGUE MIKE
McCALL YESTERDAY WHO SAID THAT
COMBINATION OF THINGS COULD
ALLOW UKRAINE TO ESTABLISH
SOMETHING CLOSE TO ITS OWN
NO-FLY ZONE.
I WONDER IF YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
>> YEAH, I DO.
LOOK, I THINK THE -- WE CAN
ALWAYS FIND THINGS AND I DO THAT
I DISAGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AND AREAS
WHERE THEY SHOULD DO DIFFERENTLY
OR SOME DIFFERENTLY ABOUT IT,
BUT THERE IS NO DOUBT THIS IS
VERY FORWARD LEANING AND SHORT
OF A NO-FLY ZONE, GIVING UKRAINE
ALL THE TOOLS THEY CAN TO
DEFEND, I THINK THE KEY IS TO
REMEMBER THIS, A LOT OF THE
TIMES PEOPLE THINK ABOUT, LIKE,
THE AIR SPACE IN UKRAINE
CONTESTED AS A GIVEN THING,
RUSSIA HAS NO RIGHT TO CLOSE
UKRAINE'S AIR SPACE.
UKRAINE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
DEFEND THEIR AIR SPACE, EVEN TO
INVITE AN ALLY, WHICH IS WHY I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF A NO-FLY ZONE.
I THINK WE'RE DOING THE NEXT
BEST THING.
I THINK THE IDEA TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FLY IN HUMANITARIAN AID
AND IT IS NOT GOING TO WAR WITH
THE RUSSIANS, IT IS SIMPLY
SAYING UKRAINE HAS A RIGHT OF
THE OWNER OF THIS AIR SPACE TO
RECEIVE AID.
SO, LOOK, I -- THERE IS MORE WE
SHOULD DO, BUT YESTERDAY'S AID
PACKAGE WAS A SIGNIFICANT STEP,
I THINK.
>> YOU RAISE A SUBTLE POINT
THERE ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A HUMANITARIAN NO-FLY
ZONE, WHERE IN EFFECT THE
U.S./NATO WOULD PUT THE ONUS ON
RUSSIA ATTACKING, RIGHT?
FLY THE AID IN, SAY THIS IS
UKRAINIAN AIR SPACE, AS OPPOSED
TO PICK A FIGHT AS IT WERE
BETWEEN NATO AND RUSSIAN JETS IN
THE AIR AND SAY WE'LL SHOOT YOU
DOWN IF YOU'RE IN THE AIR.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
I WONDER IF YOU THINK THAT IS A
RISK WORTH TAKING, AND THE U.S.
AND NATO CAN TAKE, CALL RUSSIA'S
BLUFF.
>> SO, LOOK, I'M A BELIEVER THAT
RUSSIA WILL CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
UNTIL WE PRESENT A BRICK WALL.
ONE OF MY CRITICISMS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
REPEATEDLY SAYING WHAT WE'RE
UNWILLING TO DO.
AND, YOU KNOW, AS YOU KNOW VERY
WELL, JIM, HOW FOREIGN POLICY
WORKS, TO BE ABLE TO USE
DIPLOMACY AGAINST THE ADVERSARY
IN MANY CASES THAT TAKES A
MILITARY BACK STOP.
AND SO I THINK IF YOU SAID,
LOOK, UKRAINE HAS A RIGHT TO ITS
AIR SPACE, WE'RE GOING TO
DELIVER IT NOT JUST EVEN
HUMANITARIAN SUPPLIES, EVEN
MILITARY SUPPLIES, THE POINT IS
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO PROTECT
ITS SKIES AND WE CAN SAY SIMPLY
HERE IS THE PATH WE'RE FLYING
AND IT IS ON RUSSIA IF THEY
CHALLENGE US.
I'M JUST A BELIEVER THAT RUSSIA
IS GOING TO ESCALATE WHETHER IT
IS CHEMICAL WEAPONS, GOD FORBID
TACTICAL NUKES, NOT STRATEGIC
NUKES, THEY'RE GOING TO ESCALATE
ANYWAY IF UKRAINE BEATS THEM
VERSUS, YOU KNOW, SOMEHOW THERE
IS ONLY THEY'LL FIGHT NATO, I
GUESS.
>> BY THE WAY, WE SHOULD NOTE
SOME OF THE WEAPONS THEY'RE
ALREADY USING CAN KILL ARGUABLY
JUST AS MANY PEOPLE AS SAY A
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ATTACK.
THEY'RE USING THEM DELIBERATELY
ON CIVILIAN TARGETS.
DO YOU BELIEVE IF RUSSIA WERE TO
TAKE THAT QUALITATIVE STEP OF,
SAY, USING PHOSPHOROUS BOMBS AS
THEY USED IN SYRIA BEFORE, THAT
THE U.S. AND NATO SHOULD
DIRECTLY UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES ENGAGE MOSCOW?
>> 100%.
IT IS THE ONLY WAY TO STOP IT
FROM HAPPENING.
LOOK, IF VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
FAILING AT HIS OBJECTIVE IN
UKRAINE, HIS BACKUP GOAL IS TO
DESTROY AND KILL EVERYBODY.
CLEAR OUT THE COUNTRY, WHICH IS
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING, HIS ARMY HAS
STALLED, THEY HAVE PLENTY OF
SHELLS TO USE TO DESTROY AND
KILL HUMANS INCLUDING CHILDREN
AND INCLUDING IN A THEATER,
INCLUDING WHO ARE BURIED TODAY
BY THE WAY.
SO IF WE DON'T PUT A RED LINE
DOWN, THAT SAYS, LOOK, IT IS SAD
WE SAY, YOU KNOW, OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO TOLERATE, YOU KNOW,
SHELLING, BUT NOT, BUT YOU HAVE
TO PICK SOMEWHERE.
IF WE PUT A RED LINE DOWN AND
SAY THE USE OF ANYTHING LIKE
WHITE PHOSPHOROUS OR CHEMICAL
WEAPONS OR A TACTICAL NUCLEAR
WEAPON, THAT IS A RED LINE AND
WE'LL HAVE TO ENGAGE DIRECTLY.
THAT MAKES THEM USING THAT STUFF
FAR, FAR LESS LIKELY.
RIGHT NOW I FEAR THE ONLY PEOPLE
WE'RE DETERRING IS OURSELVES.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, AS YOU
HEARD PUBLICLY, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AS WELL AS HIS ALLIES
SAY THAT SOMEHOW HAD HE STILL
BEEN PRESIDENT, PUTIN WOULD NOT
HAVE DARED TO ATTACK.
THIS DESPITE THE FACT THAT AS
YOU WELL KNOW AND BIT WAY YOU
SAID YOU REGRET YOUR VOTE NOW
AGAINST IMPEACHING TRUMP FOR
WITHHOLDING MILITARY AID FROM
UKRAINE IN 2019, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION TO THAT ARGUMENT?
>> LOOK, HE WAS AN AWFUL
PRESIDENT.
AND HE WAS AWFUL ON THIS ISSUE.
THERE IS SOMETHING TO THE FACT
THAT, YOU KNOW, NOBODY KNEW WHAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS GOING TO DO BUT
THAT WAS BECAUSE HE DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT HE WAS GOING TO DO.
THAT WAS NOT A DETERRENT TO
PUTIN.
PUTIN, KIM JONG-UN, XI, OF
CHINA, THEY'RE GETTING
EVERYTHING THEY WANTED WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK AS JOHN BOLTON HAS SAID,
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS WAITING UNTIL
DONALD TRUMP WAS RE-ELECTED AND
THEN PULL US OUT OF NATO WITH
THIS ATTACK.
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
LOOK, IF ANYBODY TRIES TO LOOK
BACK AND SAY THAT SOMEHOW DONALD
TRUMP WOULD HAVE BEEN BETTER AT
THIS, IT IS JUST UTTER GARBAGE
AND I THINK ANYBODY IN THEIR
RIGHT MIND CAN'T TRULY BELIEVE
THAT.
AND I THINK IT IS TIME TO START
TELLING PEOPLE THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN DISLIKE JOE
BIDEN, BUT DON'T ACT LIKE DONALD
TRUMP WAS ANY GOOD.
>> FINAL QUESTION IF I CAN, YOU
ARE AMONG THE NAMES MENTIONED
WHO MIGHT CHALLENGE HIM FOR THE
N
NOMINATION IN 2024, SHOULD HE
DECIDE TO RUN.
DO YOU BELIEVE THERE WILL BE A
COMPETITIVE GOP PRIMARY, THAT
YOU WILL GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO?
WE SAW STEPS IN 2020 WHERE THE
GOP CLOSED THE PATH TO
CHALLENGES.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN OR WILL YOU GET A SHOT?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
INTERESTED IN IT.
IT IS NOT SOMETHING I'M
PURSUING.
I WANT OUR PARTY TO BE BETTER, I
WANT OUR COUNTRY TO BE BETTER.
IN TERMS OF, YEAH, I THINK
SOMEBODY WILL CARRY THE TORCH OF
WHAT I CALL ACTUALLY PRO
AMERICAN REPUBLICANISM, AND I
DON'T KNOW WHO THAT NECESSARY
LITTLLY
WILL BE.
THERE IS A LOT OF DESIRE OUT
THERE FOR SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
BUT IF DONALD TRUMP GETS THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION, THERE ARE
MANY OF US THAT WILL MOVE HEAVEN
AND EARTH TO ENSURE HE DOESN'T
WIN.
I THINK THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT,